foreign
our next question is from Greg in Tampa
Florida
this is Greg calling from Tampa Florida
so my house is it's kind of a disaster
pretty much everything is just messy
enough that I know I really need to just
declutter and Purge but it's not bad
enough to keep me from like functioning
or finding things like I'm not a hoarder
but it is enough stuff that it kind of
stresses me out when people come over
and I would just love to you know be
more organized overall as a person so
where do I start with that like how do
you become a quote-unquote organized
person Kristen I I love this question
how do I become an organized person I
don't think being an organized person is
really the goal though because you can
organize everything and still have a
bunch of stuff it's just not messy
anymore it is true that a messy home is
sort of a sign of dysfunction I'm not
using that moral I'm not saying that's a
bad thing but having a messy home is a
symptom of something else it seems like
it can be yeah and so I think what does
it mean to be organized to you like what
I think that like you were talking about
adding value and that that was your
question that you asked I always like to
ask my clients why are we here what is
your bigger goal do you want to feel get
better sleep more time with your family
a stress-free morning routine whatever
it is it could be small it could be big
figuring out what that is so for the
caller
what is his why and once you really know
that and again part of going through the
decision making process your why is
going to become more clear so it might
be kind of loose and ethereal at first
then it's going to get more crystallized
as you go through and continue to let go
I also would argue that disorganization
is not always like the way we would see
disorganization in clutter is not always
a sign of dysfunction I asked my
father-in-law for permission to use him
as an example today uh he's a retired a
middle school English teacher and his
wife and my husband and I have tried to
organize his desk so many times and
within date he didn't ask us to so
that's the key
within days it was back to you know
square one but I don't feel like he's a
dysfunctional person he's one of like
the people I admire most in the world
he's so smart and always sharing
knowledge with people and always like
caring for the ones he loves so I feel
like for him trying to keep a system
that would look organized to us would
actually slow him down so the more I get
get into my work the more I'm
learning that I think when I first
started off I was like this is the way
minimalism you're keeping too much I
know it
what I've realized is you don't expect
your clients to become minimalist yeah
and what you've learned there you said
your father-in-law yeah yeah so what
you've learned from your father-in-law
is that the thing that is messy to you
may not be messy to him yeah so there's
no dysfunction there because it's not
messy to him even though if it was your
space it would be dysfunctional for you
so it's highly individual it is his
visual sensitivity is not on the level
that mine is so to he doesn't see that
um we also talk about like clutter
thresholds everybody has a different one
um so I think his clutter threshold is a
lot higher I think the only time it
causes any issues is if his wife is like
come on time to clean up you know she's
very tidy butt oh man I like to do like
a little word play with order yeah you
can think of order as something being in
its proper place but also order as a
command right and so something that
you're being compelled to do and so the
way you get ordered with your things is
by paying attention to the orders that
are coming from your soul what are you
compelled to do from within and that
helps you get organized from without and
one of the things I hear in Greg's
question is this tension that's coming
up when people come over to visit and it
seems like there's a connection there
that that's part of his why that he
likes having company he likes playing
host and this is when it bothers him but
when he's alone I can kind of deal with
it and manage it so hey it could be a
way to work work that angle by saying
I'm going to throw a party or have
someone over I'm just going to have
company over game night dinner coffee
tea conversation doesn't have to be
oriented around things and I'm gonna do
that once a week or once every other
week or once a month enough to create
that consistent pain point to where I am
motivated to get my place situated in a
way that's conducive to how I really
want to live in it I love that yeah it's
funny you said the Clutter threshold
that is so mine is probably a little
higher than Josh's I don't know if you
know this or not but my nickname is the
messy minimalist I do yeah so it's like
you know my wife and I don't have a lot
of stuff but like I'm really bad at like
putting it away it's like if I take my
jacket off it's like going on the couch
if I get mail like I'll put it on the
counter I'm like I'll get to that later
and of course you know later turns into
tomorrow and I add to that pile so uh I
mean I tried to catch myself in those
moments and I get better and better at
it over time but Greg I can tell you as
a recovering messy minimalist uh commit
to putting things away when you take
them if you take your shoes off put them
right where they belong when you take
your coat off put them right where they
belong it's funny because since I've
been doing this sometimes I'll forget
I'm like oh where's my jacket oh I'm
like oh it's in the closet that's right
Mariah why is my jacket where it's
supposed to be exactly exactly but it's
funny because what happens is like I
will you know have stuff here and there
and then I hit my clutter threshold and
I'm like okay it's time to it's time to
put everything away now I can't stand
this anymore yeah you know the funny
thing about Ryan he actually owns less
stuff than I do it just looks like he
owns more things he owns 14 things but
they're strewn everywhere exactly
strategically I remember we were
roommates together uh way back a long
time ago in Montana and uh yeah he would
just come home and not think he didn't
have that same visual sensitivity right
but his why was like oh I don't want to
frustrate the other people in the house
and so quite often understanding what
that why is for you if you don't have
that because clearly Greg doesn't have
that sensitivity no and that's okay you
don't have to have it you sh it's not
that you should have it right but if
there's something that's bothering you
it probably means you have a little bit
of excess and if it's a little messy to
you the way you can achieve calm because
decluttering isn't going to make you
happier but a lot of excess might make
you significantly more discontented and
so it's this weird dichotomy because we
often think if I just clean up my house
now I'm going to be perfect I'm going to
be happy I'm going to be complete well
no but the best way to incomplete
yourself is to keep a bunch of excess on
there that just gets in your way you're
either literally tripping over it or
you're psychologically tripping over it
yeah yeah so I feel like
when I feel like the clutter in our
space is this constant distraction like
like notifications on your phone and
yeah when when my client that I was
describing before cleared that she was
able to identify all these other things
in her life that weren't working
um so I think if you if you start there
you're faced to deal with yourself
and so that's where the inner work often
begins
um after the outer work is complete yeah
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free